the Intel I nine nine nine hundred K is
going to have eight course in 16 threads
and may overclock all the way to five
gigahertz
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies first of all
what even is the ninety nine hundred K
well this is expected to be the chip
that has been long awaited to fill in
the space of the octa-core CPU for the
mainstream platform from Intel it was
originally expected that the i7 9700 K
will fill the spot and have eight cores
and 16 threads but the 9700 K is
actually only going to have six cores
and twelve threads and this CPU is
actually going to fill in that space so
it's the nine nine hundred K worth it
and should you wait for it and conserve
buying it first let's take a look at the
performance because if the performance
isn't good then it doesn't really matter
what price or release date is really
associated with the CPU and in the past
anta has always delivered great CPUs
which deliver great performance their
CPU upgrades are not always as big as we
would like them to be and their CPUs are
expensive especially compared with the
Rison however there really is no
argument that Intel CPUs are bad or that
they don't perform well usually Intel
CPUs are a lot better at overclocking
and much better optimized for
productivity oriented programs and apps
when compared with Rison so starting off
what is the expected clock speed while
looking back at in toast last 8 core CPU
which was the 78 20x this base clock was
3.6 gigahertz and his max clock was 4.3
gigahertz but that was before the launch
of the risin 720 700 X horizon 727 or X
has a base clock of 3.7 gigahertz and a
max clock of 4.3 gigahertz and it's also
an octa-core processor with 16 threads
and as a result I really doubt that
Intel would want to release the CPU
especially a flagship CPU that is not as
good as AMD's flag from CPU so keeping
that in mind I definitely believe that
the 9900 K will have a base clock we're
just hired
three point seven year Hertz and IMAX
turbo clock which is higher than four
point three gigahertz we can probably
expect a base clock of about four
gigahertz and IMAX turbo frequency at
four point five to four point seven
years plus Intel CPUs are usually able
to overclock past the max official boost
clock and as a result even if the max
official boost clock is only four point
five meters most people will be easily
able to get to four point seven or 4.80
Hertz if you have sufficient cooling
finally some lucky people will be able
to hit the five-year Hertz mark if in2
offers a higher official max turbo speed
like four point seven gigahertz then a
good chunk people will actually be able
to hit five gigahertz so considering all
that the Intel I $9.99 hundred K is
going to be a really powerful octa-core
CPU which will most likely be able to
overclock all the way to four point
seven five gigahertz as a result it
should easily be able to be out the
2,700 X by a good margin especially
considering Intel's better optimization
however unfortunately there is going to
be one big catch and that is price so
that's definitely something to keep in
mind the 9900 K will easily cost at
least $450 and it will most likely
comment at five hundred dollars or maybe
even more than that based on current Z
370 motherboard website page updates it
seems as if the Z 370 platform will be
able to handle 9000 series CPUs but I
have affiliate that is only for the i3
i5 i7 c reason not the i9 series the i9
9900 K will have two extra cores which
will consume more power and on top of
that I bet intone wants to ensure some
sales for the Z 390 platform so I feel
like 9900 K will only be supported by
the Z 390 platform and not the Z 370
platform as a result you will most
likely have to buy an Uzi 390
motherboard and a good CPU cooler
especially if you want to get too high
clock speeds thus even though the
performance is great it is going to come
in at a premium price so that's
definitely something to keep in mind
finally when is the CPU coming out
should you wait for it and is
worth it well this TPU will most
definitely come in October considering
last year's generations release which is
also in October and I really doubt that
Intel would want to miss out on the
holiday sales of 2018 by releasing the
9900 K at a later time in 2019 and as
for if this is worth it for you it
really comes down to personal preference
if you want the best mainstream CPU
available on the market and price really
isn't a problem then the 9900 K will be
a great cpu for you but if you are
looking for a value or don't want to
spend that much money then the 2700 X is
still much superior so really comes down
to personal preference what do you value
more the performers that you get or the
value that you get lastly something else
to also consider is rising third
generation please rise and third
generation is expected to be a huge
upgrade over rise and second generation
because it's going to be moving on to
some nanometer process and there are
rumors suggesting that image get all the
way to 5 gigahertz and it may even have
12 or 16 cores
however rising 3rd generation isn't
coming out until next March so it really
is quite a wait but make sure to keep
that in mind before you make a final
decision but that's just what I think
what do you guys think do you guys think
that you should wait for the 9900 K or
the 3800 X or do you think that both of
those chips are overpriced overpowered
unnecessary junk and that rise at 5 is
really worse at make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like this video then make sure drop a
like and consider subscribing if you
would like to see more videos just like
this one but until next time bye
[Music]